hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass Sie mit dabei seid
der Chef der russischen Söldnertruppe
Wagner Jewgeni prigoshi ist nach allem
was wir bisher wissen Tod auch russlands
Präsident Putin hat sich heute zu dem
Tod von pregorian geäußert und den
gerade eben bestätigt und der Familie
kontrolliert wir hören da mal rein
was diesen Flugzeugabsturz betrifft so
möchte ich zunächst den Familien aller
Toten mein aufrichtiges Beileid
aussprechen es ist immer eine Tragödie
und wenn es tatsächlich Arbeiter der
Firma Wagner waren wie es in der ersten
Quellen heißt dann möchte ich erwähnen
dass es sich um Menschen handelt die
einen bedeutenden Beitrag zu unserer
gemeinsamen Sache des Kampfes gegen das
neonazi-regime in der Ukraine geleistet
haben
wir erinnern uns daran wissen das und
werden es nicht vergessen
so weit russlands Präsident Putin ja
pregorian der soll gestern beim Absturz
seines privatflugzeugs ums Leben
gekommen sein das sind die Bilder die
ihr jetzt gleich seht die uns gestern
Abend erreicht haben sie sollen die
Maschine zeigen wie sie ja regelrecht
vom Himmel fällt und auf dem Boden in
Flammen aufgeht der Flieger war auf dem
Weg von Moskau nach St Petersburg wo
Pregarten ins Firmen sitzen insgesamt
zehn Menschen sollen bei dem Absturz
gestern ums Leben gekommen sein den Tod
von trikotin hat gestern Abend die
russische Luftfahrtbehörde mitgeteilt
auch der telegram Kanal Grayson
bestätigt das über den hatte Pregarten
in der Vergangenheit seine Botschaften
verbreitet laut diesem Kanal stand auch
der Russe dimit gehen als rechte Hand
der als rechte Hand von pregorian Guide
mit auf der Passagierliste auch heute
ist immer noch unklar warum die Maschine
abgestürzt ist wurde sie möglicherweise
abgeschossen und das zwei Tage zwei
Monate auf den Tag genau 2 Monate
nachdem zum Aufstand gegen Wladimir
Putin aufgerufen hatte ist dieser Tod
der Absturz möglicherweise die Rache
Putins darüber wollen wir unter anderem
sprechen mit meinem Kollegen Armin
Körper den ihr jetzt auch schon im
Hintergrund seht der liefert uns dann
gleich die aktuellsten Informationen zu
dem Flugzeugabsturz außerdem sprechen
wir mit Nico lange Militärexperte und
Sicherheitsexperte über die Hintergründe
und Folgen und wir schalten auch gleich
in die Ukraine zu meiner Kollegin Anne
Brühl da hat sich in der vergangenen
Nacht nämlich auch spannendes getan das
wollen wir natürlich für euch auch noch
einmal einordnen und ein bisschen besser
verstehen wie immer geht stellt gerne
eure Fragen im youtube-chat teilt eure
Gedanken oder schickt sie uns per Mail
an die Mail Adresse die eingeblendet
seht ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de und wie versprochen
komme ich jetzt zu meinem Kollegen Armin
Körper der da schon auf uns wartet hallo
Armin grüß Dich
hallo erstmal nach Mainz wir haben
gerade den O-Ton von Vladimir Putin
gesehen er hat den Tod von bestätigt was
hat er darüber hinaus noch gesagt
er hat ein bisschen erzählt dass er
pregorian aus den frühen 90er Jahren
schon aus St Petersburg kennt dass er
den Mann lange kennt er hat ihn einen
erfolgreichen und talentierten
Geschäftsmann genannt der in seinem
Leben unter einem schweren Schicksal
litt aber die notwendigen Erfolge
erzielt hat zuletzt habe brigosin und
das ist das entscheidende ernsthafte
Fehler gemacht ich denke die Botschaft
die er damit vermittelt ist klar putin
ist auch heute abend Herr der Lage und
zwar aller lagen auch in denen von Leben
und Tod
Armin wir haben uns ja gestern Abend
schon gesprochen kurz nach dem Absturz
da war die Informationslage noch sehr
dünn was weißt Du inzwischen was hat
sich in den vergangenen 24 Stunden alles
getan was kann man sagen zu den Ursachen
des Absturzes
also klar ist dass dieser Absturz keine
natürliche Ursache hatte das auch nicht
um menschliches Versagen geht das
Flugzeug wurde zum Absturz gebracht
entweder durch eine Explosion an Bord
oder durch einen Abschluss das wird hier
von Experten eigentlich unisono
bestätigt es wird verkündet dass alle
Insassen dieser Maschine tot sind es sei
noch mittlerweile alle geborgen ist ein
10 Personen es sind noch keine
genetischen Untersuchungen gemacht
worden die zur
detaillierten oder oder zweifellosen
Identifizierung der Toten Gefühlen
könnten das ist aber ein Aussicht
gestellt worden
genau dazu passt auch schon eine Frage
die wir bei Youtube bekommen haben von
wo hat panopi wie will man denn
überhaupt seriös an ermitteln wer da
tatsächlich an Bord war es gibt
natürlich diese Passagierlisten die auch
veröffentlicht wurden aber das bedeutet
ja nicht zwangsläufig dass die Person
die auch da drauf stehen in diesem
Flieger saßen
genau darüber wird natürlich hier auch
wahnsinnig viel spekuliert ich bin da
jetzt kein Experte klar ist die
menschlichen Überreste nach so einem
Flugzeugabsturz kann man ja mit bloß im
Auge nicht identifizieren aber man kann
da genetische Untersuchungen anhand von
Kleidung anhand von Körperteilen
durchführen die da schon Aufschluss
geben wie unabhängig diese
Untersuchungen sind wie transparent und
wie für uns nachvollziehbar die
Ergebnisse sein werden na da hänge ich
mein dickes Fragezeichen dran
Armin seit gestern wird in den sozialen
Netzwerken ein Interview mit Putin
wieder sehr stark geteilt darin wird
Putin gefragt was er nicht verzeihen
könnte von einem Journalisten und auf
diese Frage antwortet er Verrat hatte
Putin möglicherweise mit Pregarten noch
eine Rechnung offen
da wird natürlich hier wahnsinnig viel
drüber spekuliert das spekuliert die
ganze Welt drüber alle Menschen alle
betroffen alle Menschen die sich damit
befassen haben da eine Meinung zu das
ist natürlich in Russland nicht anders
ist doch klar der Mann der das der das
System Putin herausgefordert hat wie
kein anderer ist buchstäblich vom Himmel
gefallen da wird spekuliert ich kann und
will mich von dieser Stelle an diesem
Spekulationen nicht beteiligen
es gibt eine weitere Frage die uns bei
Youtube erreicht hat und zwar zu der
wagnertruppe deren Chef privat war wer
führt und finanziert Wagner jetzt fragt
Eisbär bei YouTube
das ist ich sag mal die 100 Millionen
rubelfrage heute Abend ganz klar ist der
Kreml hat auf diese Söldner gesetzt und
der wird es auch weiter müssen die Frage
ist jetzt auf welche wie wird man damit
umgehen hier ist zum einen immer die
Rede von einem Rad der Kommandeure bei
der wagnergruppe die quasi einen Art
eine Art havarieplan kennen würden wie
in einem solchen Fall zu verfahren ist
diesen Plan kennen wir aber nicht und
interessanterweise haben wir auch den
ganzen Tag von diesem Rad überhaupt
nichts gehört es gibt in Russland
dutzende solcher Privatarmeen zum Teil
sind die auch an staatliche
Organisationen angegliedert wie z.B das
Brom hier wird jetzt viel spekuliert ob
die Söldner von Wagner in einer andere
Organisation überführt werden ob die das
überhaupt mit sich machen lassen was die
jetzt machen werden und wer den Job von
jewgen übernehmen wird ganz klar ist es
gibt einen Plan B und es ist hinter mir
im Kreml weiß man heute abend wer diesen
Job haben wird
du hast gesagt da ist eine Prognose
schwierig trotzdem uns haben heute auch
Bilder erreicht wie Menschen Blumen
niederlegen wie sie in Teilen auch zu
Tränen gerührt sind als sie von dieser
Nachricht erfahren haben wie wie ist das
einzuordnen wie hat die wagnertruppe
selbst auf diese Nachricht von dem Tot
ins reagiert
die wagnergruppe selbst hat auf ihrem
telegram heute morgen zur Ruhe und
Besonnenheit aufgerufen es gibt aber
unzählige Kanäle die der wagnergruppe
zugeordnet werden oder ihrem Umfeld da
wird zum Teil Präsident Putin beschimpft
es wird zum Widerstand aufgerufen es
wird dazu aufgerufen dass die Menschen
sich zum Beispiel am kommenden Sonntag
alle an großen Plätzen in allen größeren
Städten des Landes versammeln sollen ob
die das tun wage ich mal sehr zu
bezweifeln in Angesicht der drohenden
drakonischen Strafen auf sowas klar ist
ja eine Person wie prigossin hat
natürlich polarisiert hier im Land
manche haben den verehrt als Helden auch
aufgrund der durch ihn erzielten Erfolge
in der Ukraine anderer haben den total
abgelehnt und das polarisiert das bringt
natürlich hier Emotionen hoch
Armin Körper vielen Dank für diese
Informationen und die Eindrücke aus
Moskau danke dir jetzt hat sich der
Kreml nach dem Absturz zum Tod von
Pregarten auch schon geäußert aber auch
der ukrainische Präsident wurde mir
selenski der hat heute auf einer
Pressekonferenz auch etwas dazu gesagt
über die Flugzeuge sprach und den
Ländern der Welt die handreichste war
das nicht das was wir im Sinn hatten
ganz ehrlich hier hatten etwas ganz
anderes
Unterstützung
wird was die nun zunächst einmal haben
wir mit dieser Situation nicht zu tun
das ist klar ich denke jeder weiß wer
daran beteiligt ist
soweit der ukrainische Präsident wir
wollen jetzt über die Auswirkungen des
Absturzes sprechen und die Auswirkungen
für den weiteren Kriegsverlauf und auch
und auch die Auswirkungen für die auf
die Situation in Russland und dazu ist
mir jetzt der sicherheits- und
Militärexperte Nico lange zugeschaltet
guten Abend Herr Lange
guten Abend wir haben gerade wohl würde
mir selenski gehört er sagt wir haben
damit nichts zu tun für wie glaubwürdig
halten sie das
sollte ich für 100% glauben würde ich
die Ukraine war es nicht und ich kann ja
offener reden als ihr Korrespondent der
gerade in Moskau ist alle haben dazu
eine Meinung vor allen Dingen haben alle
die gleiche Meinung das passt in das
Bild dessen wie Wladimir Putin Verräter
bisher aus dem Weg geräumt hat das wäre
meine nächste Frage gewesen kann Putin
tatsächlich hinter diesem Abschluss
stecken
ja wer colonium benutzt um Verräter
angebliche in London zu vergiften wer
Menschen im Ausland und im Inland
umbringen lässt wer seit 10 20 Jahren
immer wieder Oppositionelle Journalisten
andere
zu Tode kommen lässt da ist es natürlich
sehr wahrscheinlich dass das auch in
diesem Fall so ist und es war doch klar
nach dem Pregarten seinen Putschversuch
gestoppt hatte dass in Russland nicht
mehr für beides Platz sein würde und
jetzt sehen wir das Ergebnis
unser reicht ja eine Frage bei Youtube
die so lautet welchen Sinn ergeben ist
das ganze nur zu inszenieren
wir sind zur Zeit immer bei einem was
passiert sehr schnell darin eine
Inszenierung zu vermuten oder eine ganz
komplizierte Geschichte die da
eigentlich im Hintergrund läuft ich
halte das in diesem Fall für überhaupt
gar nicht wahrscheinlich
hatte keinen Grund jetzt so eine
komplizierte Sache zu inszenieren ich
glaube auch nicht dass er das gekonnt
hätte was wir sehen ist das was es ist
ein Flugzeug in dem die Wagner
Führungsmannschaft drin war und dieses
Flugzeug ist abgestürzt und alle die
dort die Insassen waren sind gestorben
ich glaube das nicht dass das in
Inszenierung war
Putin hat wenn es wirklich so sein
sollte dass er dahinter steckt damit er
einen möglichen ja jemanden aus dem Weg
geräumt der ihm gefährlich werden könnte
aber profitiert er tatsächlich auch
politisch davon
in Russland ist schwieriger geworden
viele stehen auf Sanktionslisten und
können nicht mehr reisen und man kommt
an Putin überhaupt gar nicht mehr ran
man kann mit ihm überhaupt nicht mehr
sprechen muss man sich das eigentlich
noch sechs weitere Jahre antun im
nächsten Jahr sind ja
Präsidentschaftswahlen in Russland also
es könnte auch sein dass das politisch
erst der Anfang ist von Überlegungen und
vielleicht auch von Instabilität in
Russland sehen können
eine weitere Frage die wir bei Youtube
bekommen haben und zwar von Andreas
lautet wird die Kampfmoral der Russen
wenn wir jetzt auf den Blick den Blick
auf den Krieg in die Ukraine richten
wird die Kampfmoral der Russen jetzt
nicht noch mehr geschwächt so viel
trouble mitten in Kriegszeiten hinter
den Kulissen kann doch nicht besonders
förderlich sein für die russische Truppe
was würden Sie dazu sagen
und direkter Auswirkungen dieses
Absturzes auf die Kampfhandlungen der
Ukraine sehe ich erstmal nicht aber es
stimmt was der User schreibt Unruhen in
Russland auch schon dieser Putsch und
diese fortwährenden Auseinandersetzung
da haben die Soldaten nicht das Gefühl
dass ihnen der Rücken gestärkt wird sie
fühlen sich eher ein bisschen allein
gelassen und natürlich ist es so dass
viele auch unter den normalen Soldaten
Sympathien hatten für trikotin und für
die wagnertruppe so irre das aus unserer
Perspektive klingt aber der war sowas
wie ein Mafia Pate so eine viel
väterliche Figur und vor allen Dingen
hat er ja immer mit seinen Soldaten im
Feld geschlafen er war immer nah bei den
Soldaten werden die normale russische
streitkräfteführung ja sich immer weit
entfernt aufhält und dann eine große
Distanz hat also da hatte er schon viele
Sympathien und dass der jetzt auf diese
Weise zu Tode gekommen ist das ist
vielleicht auch so bisschen so ein
Signal der Hoffnungslosigkeit in dem
Sinne dass ich nichts ändern wird
dazu passt auch noch die Frage von
Julian die lautet sind Racheaktionen
verbleibender Wagner Söldner oder
Unterstützer innerhalb der russischen
Armee wahrscheinlich für Deutschland hat
sich hat ja oft die schlechten Zustände
dort beklagt
das ist eine wichtige Frage wie jetzt
die Anführer die es noch gibt in der
wagnergruppe und die Söldner wie die
jetzt unter Kontrolle gebracht werden
können ich meine spätestens seit gestern
ist vollkommen offensichtlich dass diese
Vereinbarung mit der Putin ja auch in
die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist trikotin
geht ins Ausland die Wagner Kämpfer
gehen nach Belarus oder können in die
russischen Streitkräfte integriert
werden dass die nie das Papier wert war
auf dem sie geschrieben stand trikotin
war ja die ganze Zeit in Russland oder
in Afrika oder irgendwo anders unterwegs
keiner hat sich an irgendwas gehalten
dass der vereinfacht war das ist die
Frage was machen diese Wagner sollten
die jetzt in Belarus sind gab ja auch
Meldung den ist schon mal das
Mobilfunknetz abgeschaltet worden aber
einige haben sich wohl in Richtung
Russland in Bewegung gesetzt
was passiert mit denen die sich in die
russischen Streitkräfte integrieren
sollten und gleichzeitig ein Stück weit
unabhängig davon wird die Frage
beantwortet wie geht eigentlich das
Geschäft der wagnergruppe vor allen
Dingen in Afrika weiter wo ich glaube
das ist weitergeführt wird und gibt's
dann Angebote an diese an die ja für
Geld vor allen Dingen unterwegs sind
diese Fragen sind aber zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt noch nicht so ganz geklärt die
wagnergruppe musste aber seit einigen
Wochen z.B schweres Gerät schon an die
nationalgarage übergeben und ist
natürlich auch dadurch dass sie in
Belarus so weit weg ist erstmal abseits
des Geschehens deswegen erwarte ich
jetzt nicht unmittelbar das ist der
Aufstände gibt oder irgendeiner Art von
Widerstand
ich möchte Ihnen gerne bevor wir zu
unserer Kollegin in die Ukraine schalten
noch eine Frage mitgeben wie kann es
sein dass die komplette wagnerführung in
einem Flieger sitzt macht das Ganze
nicht unglaubwürdig fragt uns noch
jemand bei YouTube
ja da gibt es unterschiedliche Gründe
ein Grund könnte sein dass Herr
pregorian Gründer hatte jetzt auch nicht
allen da vorbehaltlos zu vertrauen und
das ist ja oft so in solchen
Organisationen das ist ja wie bei
Organisationen in der organisierten
Kriminalität wenn man nicht so ganz
vertraut was machen eigentlich da die
Stellvertreter oder die anderen dann
hält man die immer ganz dicht und hält
sie unter Kontrolle dann machen die
keinen Unfug kann mir vorstellen dass so
etwas eine Rolle gespielt hat in dieser
Organisation und gleichzeitig sind die
ja seit einigen Tagen und Wochen immer
wieder unterwegs gewesen offenbar auch
alle gemeinsam in Afrika anderswo in
Russland offenbar
öfter mit diesem Flugzeug oder mit
anderen Flugzeugen vielleicht haben sie
sich ein Stück weit zu sicher geführt
dass sie sich so bewegen können
möglicherweise war das ja auch der Trick
ihnen das Gefühl zu geben sie sind
sicher sie können da reisen können immer
wieder diese Flüge Unternehmen dass sie
dann also gedacht haben da passiert
schon nichts wenn Sie das so machen
Nico lange vielen Dank für den Moment
wir sprechen uns gleich noch mal wollen
vorher aber in die Ukraine schauen von
dort hat uns nämlich folgende Meldung
erreicht dass ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerium hat nämlich
diese Bilder die wir jetzt gleich sehen
veröffentlicht die sollen eine
Spezialeinheit zeigen ich hoffe wir
sehen sie gleich dann wisst ihr wovon
ich spreche die sagen nämlich eine
Spezialeinheit zeigen die in der
vergangenen Nacht an der auf der von
russisch von Russland besetzten
Halbinsel Krim eine spezialoperation
durchgeführt hat so jetzt sehen wir die
Bilder und zwar sein bei dieser bei
dieser Operation wie gesagt die Bilder
wurden vom ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministerium veröffentlicht
dem Feind so heißt es Zitat erhebliche
Verluste beigebracht und alle Ziele sein
erreicht worden welche Ziele genau damit
gemeint sind das wurde zunächst nicht
bekannt meine Kollegin eine Brühe die
ist gerade in der Ukraine aktuell in
Rake und uns jetzt zugeschaltet alle
anderen
hallo
welche Informationen hast du zu der
Operation von der wir gerade die Bilder
gesehen haben
ja der militärische Nachrichtendienst
hier im Land hat diese Aktion bestätigt
und allein das ist ja schon mal
bemerkenswert denn wir erinnern uns es
gab ja immer wieder seit einem gut einem
Jahr an Schläger auf Munitionsdepots in
der Krim auf der Krim Anschläge auf die
kerzbrücke und da hat die ukrainische
Seite sich ja oft zurückgehalten also
diesmal diese offizielle Bestätigung das
habe diese Operation gegeben und zwar am
äußersten westlichen Zipfel sozusagen
der Krim mit Spezialkräften mit Marine
Soldaten mit
Wasserfahrzeugen von ukrainischer Seite
wird auch war betont dass es weitere
solcher Operationen geben soll von See
Seite aus das wären dann Einsätze weit
hinter den feindlichen Linien denn die
eigentliche Front die verläuft ja sehr
viel weiter nördlich
weiß man weißt du etwas über das Ziel
dieser Operation die Krim ist ja nicht
irgendein Ort der da wieder angegriffen
wurde bzw wo die ukrainischen Kräfte
dann jetzt vorgerückt sind
ja genau die Krim ist ein sehr
besonderer Ort das ist seit 2014 von den
Russen besetzt und das Ziel ist ganz
klar und auch das hat der Chef dieses
militärischen Nachrichtendienstes klar
benannt hat gesagt das Ziel ist die
zurückeroberungen der Krim und solche
Aktionen die richteten sich vor allen
Dingen an die Ukrainer in den besetzten
Gebieten und dazu muss man wissen dass
es ja nicht nur die Krim sondern
insgesamt sind ja immer noch 17 Prozent
der das ukrainischen Territoriums
besetzt und dieses Signal soll also sein
wir vergessen euch nicht wir machen
weiter und am Ende soll die Krim befreit
werden und das hat Präsident selenski
auch immer wieder gesagt hat gesagt
dieser Krieg hat auf der Krim begonnen
und er wird dort auch enden dazu passt
super die Frage von Igel die wir bei
Youtube bekommen haben inwiefern war
diese spezialoperation auf strategischer
Ebene entscheidend
jetzt bin ich keine militärstrategien
ich würde sagen es ist vor allen Dingen
einen ein Signal an das Volk hier also
ich meine man muss sich ja auch
überlegen warum ist das heute
passiert warum gibt es heute am
ukrainischen
Nationalfeiertag dem Unabhängigkeitstag
der Ukraine dieser Aktion die
ukrainische Flagge über der Krim das hat
eine wahnsinnig hohe Symbolkraft ein
Symbol auf das viele Menschen hier im
Land hoffen die gegen Offensive die
verläuft ja weiter schleppend sie ist
mit sehr hohen Verlusten verbunden fast
jeder hier hatte Freunde
Familienangehörige die in diesem Krieg
ihr Leben verloren haben und jedem hier
ist an diesem Tag bewusst welche hohen
Preis die Ukraine gerade bei der
Verteidigung ihrer Unabhängigkeit zahlt
einer dazu passt super noch eine Frage
die wir bekommen haben und zwar nach der
Motivation in der Ukraine hat diese
Operation aus der vergangenen Nacht
möglicherweise auch Auswirkungen auf die
Moral der Menschen
ja das ist sicherlich die die Hoffnung
die die
militärische Führung hier auch hat weil
man natürlich merkt dass ich so eine
gewisse Kriegsmüdigkeit würde ich es
vielleicht gar nicht nennen einstellt
aber die die Menschen hier sind schon
mürbe das kann man schon sagen also die
Zivilbevölkerung leidet unter diesen
dauerhaften Angriffen und zwar überall
im Land die dieser Krieg der
konzentriert sich ja nicht auf die Front
sondern in jeder ukrainischen Stadt muss
man eigentlich jederzeit damit rechnen
dass russische Bomben oder Drohnen einen
treffen und natürlich zermürbt dass die
Menschen und trotzdem ähm haben wir
immer wieder wenn wir mit den Leuten
sprechen sagen die uns was ist denn die
Alternative wir müssen irgendwie
durchhalten wir sind angegriffen worden
und wir wollen nicht von den Russen ähm
in in russische Besatzung gehen wir
müssen weiter kämpfen das erzählen uns
eigentlich die allermeisten Menschen mit
denen wir sprechen
eine brüll live aus der Ukraine vielen
Dank für deine Einschätzung und wenn ihr
weiter Fragen oder Gedanken dazu habt
dann immer gerne her damit es hier in
den Kommentaren bei Youtube oder per
Mail ihr kennt das Spiel und ich gebe
dir dann weiter an den sicherheits- und
militär-experten Nicole lange mit dem
ich jetzt wieder sprechen kann
hallo Herr Lange noch mal
hallo gibt es denn wir haben jetzt
gerade über die Grimm gesprochen haben
uns das auch von meiner Kollegin Anna
Brühl noch mal einschätzen lassen sie
hat sich jetzt ein bisschen
zurückgehalten bei sozusagen
strategischen militärischen Zielen auf
der Krim wie ist da ihre Einschätzung
die Krim ist ja ein Ort der nicht nur
ein Aufmarschgebiet ist sondern auch ein
Ort an dem zum Beispiel
luftverteidigungssysteme Systeme die
eigentlich den größten Schutz dienen
aber die auch Raketen auf Prozesse
schießen aber auch Radare und
elektronische
kampfführungssysteme der russischen
stationiert sind und solche kleinen
Schläge können ja zum Beispiel dazu
dienen ein bestimmtes Radar ein
bestimmtes System zu beschädigen oder
auszuschalten diese Einsätze des
ukrainischen Militär Geheimdienstes die
Erfolge natürlich normalerweise geheim
und das war eben die Besonderheit dass
man am ukrainischen Unabhängigkeitstag
über diesen Einsatz berichtet hat
eine Frage die uns auch bei Youtube
erreicht lautet welche Konsequenzen
werden für die zukünftige Lage Russlands
und des Ukraine Krieges gesehen also wie
muss man diese beiden Ereignisse gestern
der Flugzeugabsturz in der vergangenen
Nacht diese sehr prominent verkündete
spezialoperation welche Auswirkungen hat
das möglicherweise
also der Flugzeugabsturz hat nur
Auswirkungen auf die
Kampfhandlungen in der Ukraine wenn sich
die Instabilität in Russland fortsetzt
wenn jetzt noch mehr Dinge passieren
wenn es weitere Diskussionen gibt wenn
sozusagen mit diesen Mafia-Methoden
weitere Aufräumarbeiten durchgeführt
werden wenn vielleicht auch in der
militärspitze Generation ist ja einen
Tag vorher entlasten worden noch weitere
Entlastung da sind also wenn die Unruhe
anhält dann könnte das eine negative
Wirkung auf die russischen Streitkräfte
haben
was die ukrainischen Operation auf der
Krim angeht passen die ja zu dem was die
Ukraine schon seit geraumer Zeit macht
ja auch mit den Marschflugkörpern zum
Beispiel den Storm Shadow und den Skype
Budget nämlich die Logistik die Führung
die Kommunikation der russischen Seite
immer wieder anzugreifen und zu
schwächen und auf der Krim geht's
besonders auch noch darum von dort
starten Flugzeuge die die Ukraine
beschießen von dort sind Raketen auf
Odessa abgeschossen worden und man kann
sich ja nicht die ganze Zeit beschießen
lassen ohne mal die Ursache zu bekämpfen
und da geht's also auch um diese Bastion
Systeme die Raketen auf das Wasser
geschossen haben kann
ist denn tatsächlich davon auszugehen
dass die Ukraine mit weiteren
spezialoperationen versucht noch weiter
auf die Krim vorzurücken wie ist da ihre
Prognose
das ist davon auszugehen dass der
ukrainische Militärgeheimdienst ständig
Spezial Operationen durchführt aber da
ja ein Geheimdienst ist macht er das im
Geheimen die Besonderheit Bestand heute
darin das ist jetzt an die
Öffentlichkeit kam mit Absicht mit
Videos und mit einer klaren Botschaft
zum Unabhängigkeitstag solche
Operationen auch teilweise tief in
feingebiet also in von Russland
besetzten Gebieten werden im Grunde
ständig durchgeführt und das wird auch
so weitergehen
eine Anmerkung die uns noch bei Youtube
erreicht lautet das die Kritik des
US-Militärs des die würde lauten die
Ukraine bündelt ihre Angriffe nicht
stark genug ist die Strategie der
Ukraine durch die fuseaktion die
russische Verteidigung auseinander zu
ziehen
zunächst einmal
würde ich sagen wir tun gut daran wenn
wir uns mit mit Kritik zu Strategie und
Taktik der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
zurückhalten
wir haben keine Erfahrung damit wie man
in so einem offenen Gelände wo alles so
weit hineinsichtlich ist bei diesen
vielen Minenfeldern gegen solche
Befestigungen ohne Luftüberlegenheit
eigentlich militärische Fortschritte
erzielt und ich finde es passt auch
nicht ganz zusammen wenn man sagt die
Ukraine sollen wir jetzt mal schneller
und stärker und entschlossener gegen die
russischen Verteidigungslinien vorgehen
wenn man bei der Unterstützung der
Ukraine selbst immer ängstlich und
langsam und zögerlich ist also wir
sollten uns darauf konzentrieren wie wir
die Ukraine unterstützen können und uns
mit solchen zurufen von der Seitenlinie
eher zurückhalten die Ukraine hat sich
darauf verlegt
mit kleineren Einheiten kleine Vorstöße
zu machen und jede russische Stellung
einzeln anzugehen weil die großen
Durchbrüche am Anfang vor einigen wegen
der Mischung aus Minenfeldern und
russischer Luftüberlegenheit mit
Hubschrauber und mit Flugzeugen das hat
einfach nicht zum Erfolg geführt jetzt
probiert man was anderes mit diesem
kleineren Vorstößen und wir sehen ja
gerade in den letzten Tagen dass die
Ukraine an zwei Stellen an der Südfront
zwar langsam aber dann doch vorankommt
und gleichzeitig ist die Ukraine sehr
aktiv um die Logistik den
munitionsnachzug den Treibstoff
Nachschub der Russen immer wieder
anzugreifen und zu schwächen und auch
das scheint einigen Erfolg zu haben die
große Schlacht oder der große Durchbruch
sind bisher ausgeblieben und wir müssen
glaube ich uns darauf einstellen dass
das sehr lange dauert was die Ukraine
davor hat wir dürfen aber auch nicht den
Fehler machen zu denken dass er jetzt
ein Part und jetzt geht da gar nichts
mehr voran die Ukraine kommt voran aber
eben langsam
wir haben eine Frage noch die genau
darauf abzielt auf dass sie gerade
sagten von Julian halten Sie die
Abschneidung der russischen
Nachschublinien durch die Lieferung von
Taurus überhaupt für möglich also diese
Marschflugkörper die die Ukraine auch
gerne von Deutschland geliefert haben
möchte welche Relevanz könnte die
Lieferung sonst noch haben wie schätzen
Sie das ein
also ich halte das für möglich nicht
durch Taurus allein aber Taurus ist ja
auch gar nicht als sozusagen gamechanger
oder als der besonders neue besonders
andere Waffe gedacht sondern die
britischen Streitkräfte liefern ja schon
Storm Shadow Marshmallow Körper die
französischen
aber damit die Ukraine die Ziele im
Süden der Ukraine und auf der Creme eben
dauerhaft bekämpfen kann immer wieder
und alle davon braucht sie ein ständigen
Nachschub von diesem Marschflugkörpern
und Taurus ist aus meiner Sicht eher
Instrument damit dafür zu sorgen dass
die Ukraine eben über längere Sicht
immer für diesen muskelkörpern welche
zur Verfügung hat wir würden da also
einen Beitrag zu leisten es gibt eine
Besonderheit von Taurus nämlich dass die
Sprengköpfe besser dazu geeignet
scheinen z.B drücken zu zerstören Storm
da sehr genau aber die schlagen da ein
Loch durch man müsste ja diese Brücken
wirklich ganz zerstören um die
logistischen Linien abzuschneiden und
das geht mit Taurus meiner Meinung nach
besser
ich würde abschließend noch gerne die
Frage von Tobias weitergeben um noch mal
zur wagnertruppe zu kommen und zwar
lautet die Frage Witz die wagnergruppe
sich jetzt gegen die russische Führung
stellen
also Teile der wagnergruppe haben das ja
bei dem Putsch getan Teile der
wagnergruppe haben das jetzt auch in
Messengern und in sozialen Netzwerken
getan teilweise mit drastischen Worten
man weiß dass Herr pregorian einen
Testament hinterlassen hat und das ist
einen Beschluss gibt was eigentlich
dieser Rat der Kommandeure der
wagnergruppe tut falls ihn plötzlich zu
Tode kommt aber sind eben ein Teil der
wagnergruppe gerade in Belarus ein Teil
ist in Afrika ein Teil ist in Russland
und sollte sich in die russischen
Streitkräfte integrieren es bleibt die
Frage offen wie handlungsfähig die
eigentlich sind und was aus dieser
Haltung die sie ausgedrückt haben auf
Telegramm gegen die russische Führung
auch gegen was daraus wird ob die
tatsächlich etwas unternehmen können das
werden wir glaube ich erst in den
nächsten Tagen sehen einige haben gesagt
sie haben sich aus Belarus in Richtung
Russland in Bewegung gesetzt aber wir
können da im Moment noch nicht sehen
oder wirklich was beobachten und der Rat
der Kommandeure selbst hat sich noch in
keiner Weise geäußert darüber was die
wagnergruppe jetzt eigentlich vorhat
oder Teile der wagnergruppe Vorhaben ich
glaube das müssen wir abwarten und das
werden wir weiter beobachten vielen Dank
Nico lange Militär und
Sicherheitsexperte danke für die
Einschätzung und die Antworten auf die
vielen Fragen heute sehr gerne genau wir
waren heute live ZDF heute live weil der
russische seltener truppenchef nach
allem was wir wissen bisher nach allem
was wir bisher wissen tot ist auch der
Präsident Russlands Putin hat den Tod
heute bestätigt und der Familie
kondoliert es sind zu diesem Absturz der
sich gestern ereignet hat noch viele
Fragen offen wenn ihr da auf dem
aktuellen Stand bleiben wollt dann
schaut jederzeit gerne vorbei in unserer
App ZDF heute vielen Dank es gab
wirklich heute super viele Fragen von
euch ganz viele Kommentare und Anregung
danke dafür einen schönen Abend für euch
und bis bald